la guerre des ordinateurs a peut-être
commencé depuis quelques semaines les
rumeurs de sabotage se sont multipliées
se vérifiant parfois des virus
insidieusement inoculé dans les
ordinateurs par des informaticiens
pirates détruire et les programmes
saturant les réseaux pour tuer la
mémoire de la machine intelligente
explications patrick esther dans cette
société qui édite 350000 programme
informatique chaque année on travaille
beaucoup avec des logiciels expédié par
des auteurs professionnels ou amateurs
qui cherche à vendre leur production
je traitement de texte ou fichiers une
trentaine de programmes enregistrés sur
disque magnétique arrive ainsi dans ce
bureau
chaque mois parmi ceux là vers la mi
février nous avons reçu ce logiciel qui
était soi disant destinée à protéger
logiciel contre le piratage et nous
sommes très il avait reçues quand
décortiquant ce logiciel il avait
uniquement pour mission de bloquer
l'ordinateur de test
force était de constater que le
programme expédié par la poste
dissimulés parfaitement un autre
programme destiné à lui à détruire
on demande donc aux concepteurs de
programmes maison un petit génie
d'analyser en détail cet intrus que les
spécialistes ont surnommé un virus en
faisant une analogie avec les virus qui
contamine les cellules humaines pour les
détruire un virus qui se reproduit tout
seul
extrêmement rapidement cassant tout sur
son passage
bien nous avons analysé le virus qu'une
par ligne pour voir de quelle manière
ils se reproduisait et comment il
faisait pour se reproduire aussi
rapidement et pouvait rester par là même
une multitude d'ordinateurs en un temps
record et ça a été facile en fait pas
tellement parce que le viol c'est à ces
messieurs dans sa conception ce cas
concerne les micro ordinateurs
mais on sait que des virus circule aussi
sur les gros systèmes les virus capable
de paralyser des centres de calcul
entier en effaçant toutes les mémoires
d'un coup les grands centres
scientifiques la nasa l'agencé spatiale
européenne reçoivent périodiquement la
visite de pirates
l'introduction d'un virus pourrait être
dramatique on peut envisager à un niveau
mondial effectivement à l'heure où
les missiles stratégiques de poser de
plus en plus de ces bombes douce qui
vont détruire l'intelligence de l'ennemi
par l'intermédiaire encore une fois de
ses programmes cacher on peut également
envisager que des terroristes utilisent
ce nouveau type d'action pour faire
parler d'eux et également pour
déstabiliser voire désorganisée et par
entier l'économie dans les cas déjà
identifié de virus
on n'a jamais rien su des auteurs ni des
raisons pour lesquelles ils ont créé ces
programmes
la seule chose que l'on sait avec
certitude c'est qu'ils l'ont fait dans
le but délibéré de nuire à qui pour quoi
mystère